In almost all respects, Kevin O’Reilly is
your average 50-something Irish Man.
He lives in County Cork with his wife, Martha
where he spends his days working at a local
accountancy firm, and during his free evenings,
he likes to take quiet walks through the nearby
woods.
There’s only one remarkable thing that can
be said about Kevin: He was the second human
ever to encounter an example of SCP-3199,
a dangerous Keter-Class anomaly that has the
power to knock humanity off the top of the
food chain if left unchecked.
We know what you’re thinking: What about
the first human?
Don’t worry, we’ll get to him, but we
can assure you: He’s anything but unremarkable.
Back to Kevin.
He was enjoying one of his nightly walks when
he heard a horrible shrieking sound in the
distance.
It sounded like a woman was being murdered
and just hearing it chilled poor Kevin to
his core.
His first instinct was to run to the woman’s
aid and do whatever he could, but there was
a lurking anxiety under the surface.
The echoing memory of an old childhood legend:
The Banshee.
A monstrous, ghostly woman of Irish folklore,
whose blood-curdling screams always foretell
death.
But those were all just stories, surely?
Grim omens to stop children from straying
too far from the path.
Kevin took his first brave step in the direction
of that awful screaming, repeating the quiet
mantra of “There’s no such thing as monsters”
to himself again and again.
If only he knew just how wrong he was.
He ran deeper into the forest, following the
awful sounds.
Whoever this woman was, she certainly had
some pipes on her - the screaming had been
going on for minutes on end now, and it didn’t
seem to show any signs of subsiding.
The sky above had darkened from evening to
full on night by the time Kevin reached the
source of the screaming.
Kevin found himself in a clearing in the forest,
but in all his years of walking down here,
he’d never seen it before.
There was a ramshackle old cottage, rotten
with age and damp, and next to it, a rusty
old hut made from corrugated iron.
Like a kind of oversized chicken coop.
From the tinny, echoing quality of the screams,
he knew that they were coming from inside
the hut.
Was a woman being held captive here?
Kevin was a smart man.
He approached the tin hut quietly, not saying
a word.
If this woman had indeed been captured and
was now being held against her will, it wouldn’t
help the situation to potentially alert her
captor to his presence.
This quick thinking is the reason that Kevin
O’Reilly is still alive today.
Because, when he arrived outside the tin hut
and peered in through the window, what he
saw inside was not a woman.
In fact, it wasn’t even human.
The beast that Kevin saw inside the hut was
nothing short of a crime against nature.
A twisted abomination that was only vaguely
humanoid.
Its bloated, fleshy body, dripped with some
kind of viscous fluid, and it looked more
like a plucked, rotten chicken than a person.
The creature was shrieking and wailing, its
huge body convulsing in the coop.
It was making a gurgling, gagging noise, like
something was strangling it.
Kevin felt like he was going to be sick.
But the monster beat him to it.
It doubled over, its wretched, lipless mouth
stretching open to freakish proportions, and
started to vomit something out.
It was a gray, leathery mass, covered in dark
red blood, that soon flopped out onto the
ground, among a number of other masses that
looked just like it.
The creature then gave one final wail, and
spewed out a red stream of blood and bile
onto the masses.
That’s when Kevin realized what he was looking
at: Eggs.
A pile of big, unnatural eggs.
The foul-smelling bile that the creature had
just vomited up had no effect on the eggs,
but it seemed to burn and corrode the surrounding
environment.
It hissed against the metal as thin wisps
of steam rose from the scorch marks.
Kevin was horrified but also entranced by
the bizarre sight - until the creature stood
back up, and began to turn towards him.
Kevin didn’t let his morbid curiosity get
the better of him.
He turned and sprinted out of the forest,
knowing that if he lingered for even a second
longer, he wouldn’t return home alive.
He ran and ran, and finally heard the wailing
fade into the distance behind him.
This was the first ever outside brush with
a specimen of SCP-3199, also known as “Humans,
Refuted.”
Sadly, it would be far from the last, and
would remain one of the rare few that wasn’t
deadly.
When Kevin got back to town he immediately
told everyone what he saw.
There’s a monster in the woods, and it’s
breeding!
He even told the local newspaper, which printed
the headline, “BEAST SIGHTED IN LOCAL FOREST.”
It was enough to get the SCP Foundation’s
attention.
Field Agents were sent to the town proper
to suppress the information leaking about
the creature and gather any additional information
they needed to assess whether they were dealing
with a real anomaly here, or just another
crank.
Straight away though, the agents could tell
from Kevin’s demeanor that he’d seen something
truly awful.
He was given amnestics, and Mobile Task Force
Omega-19 were dispatched to secure and contain
the creatures that Kevin had seen.
They had twelve well-armed personnel, trained
and prepared to deal with anything.
Or so they thought.
They were led by Corporal Duncan, a seasoned
MTF operative, and they used state of the
art night vision technology to gain a tactical
advantage in the dead of night.
All they had to work on though was the visual
description provided by Mr. O’Reilly.
It didn’t take long for them to find the
same clearing out in the woods.
There was the rotten old cottage and the metal
“coop”, just like Kevin had described.
Two younger MTF members, Private MacLeod and
Private Langley, were eager to take the lead
and prove themselves as they explored the
dilapidated nightmare of a house.
Once inside, they heard strange noises, what
they assumed must have been footsteps coming
from deeper in the home.
They crept further in, and that’s when Private
Macleod first noticed it: The shape of a large,
pale, bulbous figure at the end of a long
hallway, shivering slightly in the cold.
Compared to some of the hardened killers he’d
heard about in combat training, this creature
looked like a piece of cake.
This half-man, half-chicken - it was almost
a walking joke.
He leveled his weapon and grinned as he approached
the creature.
But Private Macleod had made a fatal mistake:
He underestimated his enemy.
In a later Foundation debriefing interview,
Corporal Duncan would report with a dull horror
what he saw happen to Private Macleod that
terrible day.
He’d never seen a smile fade from someone’s
face so fast, as the creature turned, shrieked,
and sprinted down the hallway towards Private
Macleod.
The poor Private barely even had time to raise
his gun, his hands quivering with panic.
Though even if Macleod had been quicker on
the draw, it probably wouldn’t have saved
him.
As the beast approached, it spewed its foul,
stinking red bile out onto Macleod’s face.
It was a sudden burning sensation so powerful
that he passed out in an instant, his lower
face dripping off of his own skull.
He was dead in mere moments.
Then, the beast leapt forwards and began attacking
Private Langley, biting and striking and spewing
more of its deadly acidic liquid.
By the time it was done, there was barely
any of Langley left to retrieve from the house.
The ten surviving task force members opened
fire on the creature, but along with being
surprisingly fast it could also apparently
take quite a licking.
Even when Corporal Duncan managed a direct
hit on the creature’s chest, blowing a portion
of it away, the monster just let out the most
awful scream and continued fighting.
Corporal Duncan admits that, to this day,
that scream, and the moonlight shining through
the hole in the creature’s chest continue
to haunt him.
When the monster was finally subdued, they
were able to take it back to the nearby evac
chopper and begin the journey to the nearest
containment facility.
But things took another terrible turn during
that fateful flight.
The creature’s body began to convulse, before
vomiting out a pair of large, leathery eggs.
Without a moment’s hesitation, the eggs
began to bulge and tear open, and a pair of
rapidly-growing SCP-3199 instances crawled
out, attacking the mobile task force members
huddled together in the cramped confines of
the helicopter.
Once the second onslaught was over, only four
of the remaining ten members of personnel
were left alive.
The Foundation had discovered a formidable
new foe.
The specimens were brought back to Site-114,
and placed in a modified version of the standard
Keter-Class containment chamber.
It was fitted with acid-resistant steel walls,
and a series of transparent resin blocks to
store the specimens inside for constant observation.
But the creatures weren’t given Keter Class
for nothing: Escape attempts are frequent,
and whenever they happen, the numbers of creatures
in containment increases.
The most frightening detail of SCP-3199 is
the fact that it’s impossible to reduce
the number of them in existence.
Each creature has a unique, stomach-like organ
inside its body which holds an egg in reserve.
While it’s possible to destroy one of the
creatures, the eggs have proven to be almost
indestructible.
As a result, when one of them dies, the egg
within it hatches and immediately grows into
a replacement.
And if the creatures are ever allowed to roam
free, they begin laying eggs in any unoccupied
space they can find, causing their numbers
to grow.
In theory, if left unchecked, they could supplant
the human race with their own species in hardly
any time at all.
The only solution that the Foundation has
found is submerging the creatures in sedative-laced
water, as the beasts seem to inherently register
water-filled areas as “occupied space”,
and therefore do not begin laying eggs while
submerged.
But even the Foundation’s most optimistic
minds still admit this is only a temporary
solution.
But where did these awful creatures come from?
After the chaos of the first mission, the
Foundation had dispatched an additional Mobile
Task Force, Surface Team Delta-029-E, to perform
a second sweep of the house and figure out
what had been going on during the two decades
of proceeding silence.
Inside, the team managed to collect a number
of strange objects to bring back as evidence
of the peculiar activities that had taken
place there
Among these were a number of chicken carcasses
that bore evidence of surgical dissection,
a pair of chicken feather quills, and an A5
hard-cover notebook labeled “NEW BREED MANIFESTO.”
Its writer is believed to be deceased, most
likely as a result of SCP-3199, but the final
note scrawled inside the book and dated 1973
provides some insight into what had occurred
inside that dilapidated shack in Ireland.
It reads:
“If you're reading this, then lucky, lucky
you! 400,000 hour from now and it'll be warm
and wet and warm, and the wonderful vursatilli
vessa versatility of (INFERIOR) human DNA
will birth a better era.
A stronger era.
One where [ILLEGIBLE] and food and water will
be nothing but things of the passed as we
make and make and make more until until
I REALLY HAVEN'T MUCH TIME
TIME
THATS why i ENVY you so so so much.
you'll have all the time you need.
time will be a thing of the time will be on
and on and death will be life.
life new life needs things to live.
new life will be a part of life from now on.”
These are the last words of the deranged mad
scientist who created SCP-3199, perhaps under
the demented belief that somehow, they’d
make the world a better place.
Personally, we don’t think SCP-3199 have
any interest in improving the world, but whether
we like it or not, their insane creator is
right about one thing: They’re our problem
now.
Now go check out “SCP-610 - The Flesh That
Hates” and “SCP XK Class End of the World
Scenarios Explained” for more anomalous
entities that could bring humanity to its
knees!